voilà monsieur bonsoir tolérons
dynamique mélomanes ayant le goût du
risque ce portrait idéal que l'on peut
conjuguer au féminin n'est en fait que
le portrait robot de la [ __ ] en
ile-de-france un portrait tout à fait
dithyrambiques qui dressait par un très
sérieux centre d'études et présenté au
non moins sérieux au conseil régional
vernant ségara poursuit pour nous cette
liste inépuisable semble-t-il des
qualités du parisien moyen les habitants
d'île de france semble de plus en plus
adapté à la ville ou à la vie dans les
cités
en tout cas les habitants de la région
préfèrent l'animation des centres villes
à la solitude des petits villages même
avec en prime l'oxygène
cela dit une majorité encore la
nostalgie de la campagne mais beaucoup
moins qu'il ya dix ans 76% des français
gardent une nostalgie de la campagne il
n'y en a plus que 53 % en ile-de-france
et le mouvement est très rapide ces dix
dernières années 20 pour cent que ce
soit paris en petite couronne en grande
couronne 20% des habitants ont abandonné
la nostalgie de la campagne ce qui
prouve en tout cas qu'il ne se trouve
pas si mal que ça allait mieux encore
les parisiens ce qui manque le plus
c'est le temps de vivre plus pour les
cadres que pour les ouvriers et plus
pour les habitants de la petite et de la
grande couronne que pour ceux de paris
qui sont les gens qui manquent de temps
ce sont les gens qui font le plus de
choses c'est à dire qu'ils choisissent
finalement de manquer de temps les gens
qui manquent de temps sont les gens qui
lisent le plus qui ont le plus de micro
ordinateurs à la maison qui vont le plus
au cinéma qui reçoivent le plus leurs
amis qui voit aussi le plus leur famille
et qui garde le plus du temps pour ne
rien faire ce qui est tout à fait
étonnant
ainsi en banlieue a entonné par exemple
les jeunes sortent peu leurs loisirs
sont plus familiaux ou amicaux pas
tellement d'endroits enfin même bon bah
moi qu'on préfère de rester comme ça
entre nous ça va au se donne une soirée
chez chez l'un chez l'autre
il organise quelque chose je suis pas
soirée crêpes et n'importe quoi pour
passer sa hotte à re des choses comme ça
mais ça va pas plus loin
en ile-de-france le temps qui reste on
le consacre en priorité à la musique
la région serait paraît-il devenu un
pays musical la musique passe en avant
la famille les amis et même les
relations sexuelles ou amoureuse
décidément il n'ya plus de tabous en ile
de france